context forms the setting for an event
statement or idea and in terms of which
it can be fully understood in this
context some educators also speak of
situated learning they assume that there
is no learning per se all there is is us
changing in response to the situation
around us once a situation changes then
our thinking changes new neural
connections are created and we learn
consider the following situation
a man is sitting alone in the restaurant
and orders a salad two pizzas and a big
bottle of water what do you think we are
learning about this man in this very
moment once we add some context we learn
something new without context our
understanding is limited we misinterpret
information and draw false conclusions
for example we can present a statistic
or a company's share price in a way that
makes it look great once we add context
by looking at a longer time horizon or
comparing the development to a benchmark
we see the big picture and understand
what's really going on context also
allows us to gain a deeper understanding
of a subject matter the Russian ruler
Stalin once said when one man dies it's
a tragedy when thousands die it's
statistics he had a point to really
understand something we cannot just look
at facts and figures we have to zoom in
and look at personal stories then we
understand the true sad nature of war
how it affects the soldier his wife
their children and maybe an entire
generation to come context also matters
when we learn languages for example if
you learn German and you try to remember
the word mag which means to like
something in English you can learn it
with a sentence such as mama mag
Cuckoo's Nest
which means mum likes coconut when we
learn new words in a sentence we give it
context and your brain can link the new
word to memories of your mother and an
experience with a coconut
then a new mental image is created which
can be stored or reimagined in schools
context is often absent we learn about
trees in books instead of exploring the
woods we learn about our feelings and
behaviors from psychology books instead
of in person and we learn about maths in
theory instead of applying it to the
real world we miss the opportunity to
connect theory with practice or plain
information with personal memories
situations are not changed learning does
not happen memories are not created and
we stay pretty stupid entrepreneur Gary
Vaynerchuk predicted that context is the
new king of business use technology to
provide a solution right when people
need help
boom sold if we are in the business of
telling stories or explaining
complicated things we can do the same
when our information gets to a student
at the exact moment when they most need
it it changes the entire situation they
react to the new circumstances get
excited and actually learn
[Music]
you
you